from timcast.com Texas passes
legislation requiring 10 commandments to
be displayed in every classroom the
Bill's sponsor says the Ten Commandments
are part of American tradition under
sb15115 which just passed the Senate by
a 17-12 vote every Public elementary or
secondary school must prominently
display a durable copy or framed copy of
the Ten Commandments that is at least 16
inches wide and 20 inches tall the
display must also be legible to a person
with average vision from anywhere in the
classroom the Bill's sponsor state
senator Phil King said during a
Committee hearing on the bill that the
Ten Commandments are part of American
Heritage and that it's time to bring
them back into U.S schools oh boy wait
this is like there is no other God
before me no false Idols I mean the
second commandment basically says that
Christianity is Blasphemous you're not
supposed to worship people
are they worshiping people well this
Jesus people the Christians worship a
human and the the second command you are
incorrect that's incorrect yeah yeah you
shall not make for yourself a carved
image whether it's a human or a thing
Jesus was not God yeah
and that's what they say yeah they say
he's a human that was also God but at
the same time so hypothetic nature
exactly it defies it defies the second
commandment you're not supposed to
worship other people no but he's God he
is fully God and fully human at the same
time so you worship fully God like it's
it's the the word for it is hypostatic
Union because you cannot separate the
two so worshiping Jesus I'm Catholic
that's why I know this
um worshiping Jesus you are worshiping
God he is the Son of God he is part of
the Trinity father Son and Holy Spirit
are all one three and one so it's not
worshiping a person it is worshiping God
it's worth a person a person God but you
can't spirit all at once so it is a
person no no no no father Son and Holy
Spirit are all three all three it's
three and one it's the Trinity it is God
God took the form of a man
to come to Earth as Jesus Christ but you
are it's not separated it's not like oh
his body was human and his his Spirit
was God he was both fully God and fully
man so when Jesus is worshiping God I
don't want to know this is actually I
want to talk about this is a whole
different body I want to talk about the
the political uh oh yeah and
philosophical first for those that I
think we should tell you what the Ten
Commandments are so you can understand
what they're they want to put in school
I love the first one one no other gods
before me you shall have no other gods
before me two you shall not make for
yourself a carved image is that uh no
false Idols I believe yeah yeah three is
you shall not take the name of your lord
God in vain now this one's interesting
because
um what was explained to me I think this
was Prager who explained this that a lot
of people think it means you can't just
say something like oh my God because
you're using it for no reason but what
he described I could be wrong about who
if it was him or not but someone
described it as it would be like
declaring war an enemy country and
saying God wills it yes you are taking
his name to do your best editing and
that's taking his name oh my gosh these
super churches make me think it's also
like you know the phrase you know the
phrase Lord yeah Lord is actually like
not the name of God but in the old in
the Old Testament the the Jewish people
God's people believed that they couldn't
say the name actually Jews today still
like abbreviate when they say God they
put a little Dash between it because you
they couldn't say the name of God which
is Yahweh so that's it was four letters
Yahweh and so they they called it Lord
as a way of saying it without saying the
name of God because it's so he's has
such extreme Majesty that he couldn't
say the name let's read some more
because again I I'm not here to teach
you the Ten Commandments everybody but
for the context of I'll do that too this
is what they want to put in the schools
you should know this four is remember
the Sabbath day five is honor your
father and mother six you shall not
murder seven you shall not commit
adultery eight you shall not steal nine
you shall not bear false witness ten you
shall not covet so this is being passed
in Texas they want this in elementary
schools I guess the question is if if
they're putting critical race Theory
critical theory gender ideology in
schools personally I don't see any
difference and so my response is going
to be if you are trying to pass Marxism
into schools Then I then okay fine you
do that they do this where what am I
arguing can I tell you my super based
opinion on this sure okay my Super Bass
opinion on this is that this is fabulous
and that they should do it and then it
violates it violates nothing about our
our heritage of law here so truly in the
conservative movement the Republican
Party there's a difference between how
we view laws right there's like the
libertarian view that's like we should
be able to do whatever we want as long
as we don't violate somebody else's
fundamental human right government
should get off my lawn and then actual
conservatism is not libertarianism
actual conservatism is like in the in in
the style of Edmund Burke right where
it's not absolute Liberty it's ordered
Liberty ordered Liberty being defined as
more like the pursuit of justice and he
defines Justice because you're like okay
what's Justice then he defines justice
as
um original just says capital O original
justice meaning rooted in the
traditional judeo-christian morality and
this is not just something like oh okay
I'm a practicing Catholic I'm coming in
here with my religious views Edmund
Burke's philosophy is what our
constitution was based on
James Madison the father of our
constitution quoted Edmund Burke so my
belief is that indoctrination is morally
neutral it's not good or it's not good
or bad in and of itself and there's no
such thing as neutrality you either we
are going to be indoctrinating or they
are going to be in doctors we don't have
this in schools then Marxism which I
would argue is a form of like satanic
ideology then Marxism is going to be in
our school so I would much rather have
this do you agree with Ten Commandments
in schools yeah I think it's great I
mean there is an argument so I think
people misinterpret how America treats
religion right in France you have
freedom from religion so you're not
supposed to wear religious symbols in
school there's controversy over job
providing uh kosher meals things like
that in America you have the freedom to
practice your religion however and I
think you're completely right uh we're
actually a nation that's completely
intertwined with Christianity and so
it's not wrong to have uh the Ten
Commandments in schools I mean you can
reference it in a lot of different ways
when you're teaching right like
it's also
uh such a fundamental part of her life
that like when we talk about uh
observing the Sabbath right like this is
a case that the Supreme Court has agreed
to take on you have this uh postal
worker from Pennsylvania who said you
know I'm a I'm uh practicing Evangelical
Christian and I observe the sabbath on
Sundays and when the U.S postal work uh
service started working with Amazon they
said okay but our workers have to work
on Sunday and he said well I need a
religious exemption and eventually uh
his postal workers where he's he's based
we're like we're not going to we're
gonna we're gonna keep scheduling you
for Sundays we're not going to
acknowledge that you need a real
exemption even though our typical work
week does allow for us they said this is
critical to our business and so
therefore we are allowed this is two
judges went through and said yeah they
have the right to demand that you work
and deny your religious exemption well
you have the freedom to practice your
religion right like I think that we are
so afraid of religion as a country uh as
a country that we don't learn how to
talk about in a way that's saying like
you don't have to be a Christian but you
need to understand and Christianity to
understand the influences it has on the
country so Ian yes or no 10 Commandments
in school it depends on how it's taught
because there's a difference between
mountains on the walls that's what they
said there's a difference between
teaching about Christianity or Judaism
this Judaism there's a difference
between teaching about Judaism and
indoctrinating people to become Jew okay
wait wait hold on Ian a specific
question they are mounting this they
want this mounted in elementary schools
no I don't like it it needs context if
they're going to teach it they need to
teach about it and not just make people
think this is real you're like you have
to be able to choose to believe that
this is real
but all they're doing is putting it on
the wall yeah without context that makes
me nervous man you know I'm neutral on
it um I certainly understand why
Christians and Catholics and you know
whatever and and many Jewish people
probably would would be like yes this is
fantastic we should have these values
instilled to our children and you're
completely right about about an
indoctrination 100 I would prefer
The Ten Commandments over Marxism so if
someone came to me and said it's one or
the other I'd be like oh ten
commandments all the way but the systems
where they're like hey here's a really
horrible choice and you're like I don't
want that they're like okay here's a
little bit less horrible Choice want
that one instead you're like yeah I
guess it's less worse it doesn't have to
be either of them this is the company
this is the conference I don't think
there's anything we're not talking I'm
sorry go ahead we're not talking about
the school teaching Bible study they're
actually putting Marxism in classroom
curriculum and critical uh critical race
Theory and critical gender theory is
literally being put into math problems
this is the compromise this is we're
gonna put it on the wall and say I'd
like to see the four pillars of Islam
posted next different four pillars of
Islam our country is literally basing
this think about our laws against
homicide why do we as a people recognize
that other human beings deserve
protection under the law but like dogs
don't or something like that if you look
at morality and think about morality
there's actually no such thing as
secular morality secular morality is
just Anarchy it's just the strongest can
dominate the week the only reason that
we have order in our country right now
even as we are in a chaotic era is
because we have some acknowledgment at
the base level that people have dignity
that people have value and that's based
on that order is based on
judeo-christian values now you don't
have to practice those values in your
personal life but it is a historical to
ignore the fact that our entire system
our entire Republic is based on that
yeah is it any different than having a
dictionary in the classroom right like
if you're explaining hey fifth grader
these are what the Bill of Rights are
like here's something that influenced
that like how is having this resource
any different right like if you want to
talk about how it compares to Islam then
yeah maybe you should bring in some
tests so students can study it the truth
is Judaism is the most based religion I
think it is phenomenal because it's
about your religion your experience with
God directly you don't need a priest you
don't need any of that it's you and God
I think that is where it all comes from
all of it Christianity Islam it all
comes from Judaism but I'm following the
founding fathers saying church and state
should be separate I don't think they
ever said that I was only in one letter
that Thomas Jefferson wrote to the
Danbury Baptists to assure them that
they weren't going to face
discrimination from the government for
practicing their religious religion but
the the phrase separation of church and
state was never part of any founding
document and it's not part of any
philosophy about keeping morality out of
law it's only about whether the
government can either force you to
participate in religious practice or
prohibit it and I'm pretty sure there
was also conversely a Founding Father
maybe was Franklin or Jefferson that
said you need religion for a for a
society to function properly yeah John
Adams said our country was made for
moral people and no other yes I just I
see the churches capitalizing on
religion and that bothers me he's right
though we talk about us all the time so
the question I've asked is would the
United States be better or someone asked
us this would the country be better if
it was a Christian theocracy and first
of all better I guess is subjective but
if you were to talk about do we want
less crime do we want a stronger economy
do we do we want better health care if
everybody shared the same moral
foundations everyone's lives would be
better however I'm not saying which
moral foundations I'm just saying if you
had 100 million people that that all
agreed communism was perfect guess what
it would work the reality is communism
doesn't work because no one ever agrees
to that great extent someone's always
got to run a system or whatever that's
why communism doesn't work but if
everybody had a simple moral Foundation
that was like the Ten Commandments or
otherwise everybody agreed that that you
know there was an afterlife there was a
God you have to be good stewards of the
earth and all that you'd have to worry a
lot less about crime
the issue is right now No One Believes
or fears that there is any consequence
to the bad things they do so we
experience more crime and Corruption
where you Liz were you taught religion
as a kid yes yeah I was raised in a I
was raised in a Catholic home and then
of course you get to an age as a young
adult where you have to decide like okay
am I going to continue in this practice
as an adult and own it versus just
participate in a family one more point
about this being in schools though and
this is really interesting if you read
the history of public schools in our
country compulsory public schooling only
became a thing in like I think
Massachusetts was the first state to do
it in 1836 and the reason that they did
that the reason they had compulsory
public schooling was to indoctrinate
children in two things in American
values and in Protestant values because
at that time in our country there were
tons of immigrants coming in our country
a lot of them were catholic immigrants
and the people in charge of our
government at the time were very
anti-catholic they were very Protestant
and they wanted to form a new generation
of children that understood that they
weren't they weren't they shouldn't
identify the country that they came from
they needed to identify as Americans so
they had to be taught American Civics
and they wanted them taught Protestant
values so the purpose of our education
system has actually always been
indoctrination we've just I mean it was
just hijacked by people who wanted to
indoctrinate the opposite of what it was
intended
I was like Rockefeller let me ask you
guys I want to read the Commandments and
and then get your opinions on it so
let's because they're because they want
to teach kids this let me ask you you
all first obviously I think the the
Christians in the room are going to have
an obvious answer uh no other gods
before me shall have no other gods
before me is that something a children
should be taught in general
uh this one makes me nervous because if
I say to you Tim there is no other God
before me and I'm reading you the
Commandment there's there can be a
possibility that you think that it's Ian
there's no other God before the ego that
is speaking the words so that's one gets
misinterpreted when the guy stands up
and says it out loud it's true that
there is one God but it is not for it's
not me it's God I think that's I think
it's unlikely that people would
misinterpret it like I think but please
stand up and take take the credits
that's not my question my question is if
you is it is it a good thing to teach a
child about the one God
I'm not saying to accidentally say to a
kid a sentence and then walk away I'm
saying should should an adult be telling
a children
basic philosophies around the first
amendment yes first first Commandments
they crafted the ten the ten amendments
you know the ten Bill of Rights is kind
of like a I think part of it is like yes
as a Christian I think sounds good to me
and I can understand in a diverse
Society where there are different
religious views you might be concerned
like seeing there's only one Christian
God does that isolate someone else but I
think the idea behind this meaning that
there is one point of authority there's
one point of point of morality is a good
concept to teach people right it can
make them subservient to Authority so
you gotta be careful about that if I was
a kid and I saw that on the wall and I
didn't know what it meant I'd first
thing I would ask is what is God but
right but but declare I get it but I'm
trying to clarify I'm not suggesting
that I'm saying should children be
taught that there is one God and no
other God are you talking about by
public schools or in general in general
oh should children be absolutely yes
and it's what is it and you got to
explain what it is I'm ashing you in if
they should teach that in school to no
in general oh well yeah I think so
that's my that's why I like to do that I
think that's our job they could also
teach polytheism they could say which we
should yeah no I'm saying they go to
children and say did you know that Zeus
is a top Mount Olympus Zeus was a guy
that had electricity and he lied to
people and told him he could shoot
I believe kids that much nut job they're
a big call living up in the mountains
that's a that's a 20 and that's a 20. uh
so here's the next one sorry can't get
over it should children in general be
told not to worship false Idols yeah
absolutely I completely agree I think
you'll agree to that that was the point
love yeah for sure everyone agrees yeah
yeah but only in conjunction with the
first because you need to know what to
worship exactly and then it actually
says that says the first and second
second commandment go hand in hand I
think the second commandment is actually
not even necessarily a Christian it
doesn't need to be seen as a Christian
specific thing telling people not to
worship false Idols I think is a good
thing Jewish it's a Jewish thing these
are all Jewish yeah so uh uh we all
agree with that and and I'll just say I
think it's because there are bad things
that will try to trick you and deceive
you and you could be tricked into
worshiping bad things we're trying to
say be careful of those who would trick
you into worship money do not worship it
bad politicians I mean I gotta interject
here and say that as a Catholic
we look at the Bible as a whole not just
line by line like everything isn't
everything is Con is contextualized both
with the old Covenant and then the
Fulfillment to the New Covenant and the
gospels so it's not just good advice for
your life it all centers around the fact
that God has given us these laws in
order for us to better worship Him and
ultimately and this is I know the
religious point of view but it's not
just secular advice for your life but I
I think that's a actual component I
think these are to help you actually
live a better happy and more fulfilling
life if if I were how do you define
those words like better happier and more
fulfilling do you define those as like
just here on Earth or do you find that
do you define that like okay I'm saying
it's both on Earth your goal is actually
keeping your eyes on eternity to live
this life so you can get to the next I
will say
if your view is that this is to better
worship God that is true and correct and
I would also say if you follow them your
life will be better in general and if
you're if you're tripping on DMT and you
know this stuff you'll be better off
while you're tripping so this this next
one's it three is interesting it's funny
that we're actually discussing the
philosophy of the Ten Commandments I'm
actually really excited for this you
shall not take the name of your lord God
in vain uh I'm gonna start this one
because I am not Christian I do believe
in God and my view is call it whatever
you want call it superstitious or
spiritual I am very reluctant to curse
or tempt the fates I have that I have
had many instances in my life where I
have
I don't know how you describe it I
wouldn't necessarily say it's using the
lord's name in vain but arrogance and
then I had the python in my face where
I've made jokes thinking who cares and
then experienced an uh a thing I've had
experiences in my life where I've sat
behind my computer and mocked someone
just to myself and then a week later met
them and they were the nicest person in
the world to me just ripping my heart
out I'm like I can't believe I would
think those things about this person
that was the stupidest so I look at this
I'm like call it whatever you want I
believe there is something greater than
us and I believe insulting the universe
the greater the energy or God or or that
is just I stay away from that I think
it's a bad thing I think you will be
better off if you remain humble dude
except you're except that there are
powers Beyond you like I think God
speaks to people I have when I clear my
mind and I ask tell me what to do I get
a vision of what I'm doing and but if I
went online and said God is command
commands you to subscribe to me for ten
dollars a month like that's the vein
that's absolutely that never never that
you need to follow that commandment
you're not abuse that that thing I think
that's one interpretation of the word
vain I think the other part is saying
like you have to set boundaries for
yourself on what you're allowed to say
like being able to basically understand
what's inappropriate what's not
appropriate you are able to better
understand respect like this is
basically the concept of respecting
something that has more Authority and
knowledge than you do right and like
that is actually a good principle to
carry out in life so I'm just like the
principle of Salvation really it like
it's like the ultimate humility because
we are we are not worthy of even saying
his name let alone living forever with
him in eternity and experiencing his
love
right I I think except for that he came
to save us to kind of simplify why I
wanted to go through these as they're
talking about putting in schools is that
we need to teach basic philosophy on
like I think the idea that people say we
are what we are moist robots and there
is nothing Beyond light I'm like that's
the craziest thing I've ever heard like
any any degree of scientific
understanding philosophical
understanding and spiritual general
knowledge like General like I'm saying
if you're not a Christian and you just
read the Bible to better understand what
people think all of these things would
lead
I think any person who who is an open
minded is actually trying to learn they
would be like there is something truly
Beyond us at the very least and so you
got to teach kids philosophy I think I
think these are all really great this
could go in a science class because
you're talking about quantum physics I
mean then well let's let's let's look
remember the Sabbath day I'm fairly
neutral on this I mean I think a day off
is very important a day of rest
um I think it means something else to
Christians you know yeah I mean the
Sabbath is really about like meditation
family on your family meditating on the
philosophy of the things that you've
learned like I think that the Sabbath
day is something our culture doesn't
appreciate because we just see it as the
day before Monday I'm I'm gonna stop
right there and say you know what
probably the most important commandment
and I think everybody should should be
taught it my view is that it is not some
arbitrary thing about God's day
necessarily it is we talk about Shabbat
and how Jewish families from Sundown on
Friday until sundown on Saturday turn
off all the devices come together and be
a family that is one of the most
powerful cultural tools
in human in human Arsenal I was sitting
in front of my computer the other night
and I heard I was I just heard this
frequency in my head like
I was like what is that noise that's my
blood pressure and when my monitor
dimmed it stopped like these these
machines are driving our minds
probably probably affecting us in ways
we don't know but my point is
remembering the Sabbath one of the
things that's breaking apart Western
Civilization is that we don't congregate
with our families and our communities
anymore yeah and to your point I'd like
to the Sabbath Christian communities
right used to go to church together with
your family with Community then you'd go
home and you weren't a lot to work and
you're supposed to be talking to each
other and thinking about the lessons
that you are being taught in church
through interpretation through your
pastor or whatever else like it is about
the moral growth of both your family and
of the individual it's also the idea of
dedicating that day to God like it's I
agree with what you're saying that the
degradation of our society is because of
the breakdown of the family and the fact
that even when families are together
we're all on the devices that wreck our
brains but that commandment the
interpretation of that commandment is to
dedicate that day to God that like like
I go to mass every Sunday because that's
not that's that's I go to mass to
worship God the way that he laid out
that he wants to be worshiped right and
that's what it means to say okay that
day is your day it's not about me it's
not about my rest it's not about my
enrichment it's about you and so I will
stop everything I'm doing and worship
you and there's there's no there's no
question about any of the other
Commandments I think there's literally
no argument honor your father and your
mother big time it is I'm sorry if you
don't honor your father and your mother
if you don't love them and care of them
I understand that people have fights and
falling out and people but there's
always a love there for your family then
there's something wrong right like it is
it is 99.99 of humans who love their
parents I was just gonna ask Jazz
Jennings mother would you expect Jazz
Jennings to honor thy mother that's a
good question the the answer is as a
mother yes but if Jazz's mother is doing
her hateful and damaging things it's not
a mother it's not it's not an issue of
mother you know what I mean what do you
mean by Honor though it's the definition
of what do you mean by Honor are you
going to go out and you're going to ruin
the Dignity of this person that gave
life to you or are you gonna say listen
you've abused me and so with all due
respect I'm gonna separate myself from
that abuse say what was wrong and move
on like I think the word honor is pretty
important there it's because it's not a
matter of like oh you're abusing me but
you're my mother so I have to listen to
you for the rest often
you shall not murder yes that is taught
in all schools and to all children and
it's very important we do you shall not
commit adultery at least for the time
being we still have that cultural thing
but now you've got the rise of follicles
no no fault divorce it's crazy yeah
that's Reagan's fault it is you shall
not steal oh boy we're losing that one
but that's a no-brainer you shall not
the government needs to teach itself
that one oh it's for sure you shall not
bear false witness seriously don't lie
you know and then false witness means
like saying something accusing someone
else falsely like that's incredibly
important for our culture now like think
about all of the think about like the
Kavanaugh stuff and all these false
allegations that's deep fakes they're
false Witnesses totally yes and then you
shall not covet I I I I agree with these
and you know it's not even my my
perspective on them is not religious
yours is yeah my perspective is you will
live a better life if you understand
what these things do for humans yeah now
simply put from a religious perspective
you're saying it's to better worship God
yeah my response is okay maybe that
doesn't persuade someone but I tell you
if you follow these you'll be happy
you're healthier with a better family
better kids I think having a shared
moral understanding would make our
stronger our society stronger and I
don't need to make you go to church if
we all can agree by some basic rules and
so therefore having the Ten Commandments
in school and being like here here are
some basic rules that we all agree to
would be a beneficial thing thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time